[Music]
a myung love news submitted by Oscar D
YouTube star Tana mangu mine Joe mojo
I think it's motive it's pressure mode
you that you old man
I'm going on there then Oh mondo
announces her engagement to Jay Paul I
read this [ __ ] I don't know if it's real
no they make so many videos that are
pranking and trollee that you don't
really know what to believe and I think
like just kind of that circle there's so
much fake beef fake raps and all that
that they blow each other up so like I
don't really know what to believe
anymore from that group of people fake
breakups fake getting back together fake
all that [ __ ] yeah do you think the
[ __ ] is fake though I don't think
they're talking at all
I think oh I think they [ __ ] while
looking at the views grow don't they
I'll that'd be tight you look at your
subscriber count here's Tana and Jake I
appreciate don't hu what is that each
time Oh Houston yeah raka well I don't
think he is he from Houston I don't
think so bad I don't think you know him
no no page that's all I got for I
thought that was a W I thought was like
a wu-tang thing what's routine no that's
that's loser loner Walmart shopper this
one you shopping at Walmart you guys
that this is the Westside like a clown
we all started off strong and we ended
very sadly this is blood I think that
one's so cool as you can read it this is
peace isn't it it [ __ ] debt that one
is so cool because you can read thoughts
ads Metheny anti violence this one's
this one's the cool piece though okay so
Tana just turned 21 and Jake bought her
a G Wagen G Wagen or her birthday which
is a very expensive vehicle yeah it
could be like hundreds of thousands of
dollars yeah over yeah over 100 from the
body language it doesn't seem like she's
that into him
she's like like this like her legs up
but like they're not really firmly
pressed you know I mean like she looks
she looks like well you don't understand
IG posing for but yeah she the gram
right now can I have Bart's back real
quick knows that it doesn't it don't you
dare put me down
Bart's trying to say oh now I want to
what what Bart's trying to say is
sometimes when you're watching porn
right and you see the girl is like
banging this guy you can tell she's not
really into it oh yeah I supported one
before what's more obviously this was
consensual right yeah we know my girl
now but I thought you were like
directing a porn no no we're in
relationship and we had we recorded it
and I saw her check her phone in mid
like this she was definitely not into
this you know what she was doing when
she was checking her phone home and she
got me she was basically just like
leaving you a review in person she was
giving me a little Yelp she's like this
is what I think about she would know she
was hitting up the girlfriends leaving
the review yeah yeah I'm getting
takedown right now I saw nobody exactly
the act of checking phone is like a
three star I never brought it to her
attention either I just when I look back
I think three stars too high I think
it's a one step it's a one star just
like it was and it almost looked like it
was like you know like what
notifications do I have it wasn't even
like what is it tougher to go to work or
because it was just too embarrassing
yeah but she knew that you guys were
like yeah yeah yeah yeah we were that's
way worse we're trying to get in your
head I don't know maybe she passes we're
getting up off camera so I think she has
an addiction to the phone so it's not
your fault
this juber appreciate you fam I take my
phone all the time I'll check in my
phone Joe is like my chick takes out a
typewriter sometimes she comes
we used to make that all this is my
fault and Jake she posted on her stories
so that she was celebrating her 21st
birthday in Vegas and [ __ ] thing came
out it said will you marry me Tana and
then she kept saying
I'm engaged at Jake whoa no I [ __ ]
hate these kids because I'm a [ __ ]
because I'm just jealous I want that
kind of money to [ __ ] around
yeah I'm just hating cuz I'm jealous
[ __ ] these kids I'm hating because I
don't like their personality oh but you
don't know them see I think tan is nice
I've met her you've met her she's nice
right I thought she's not no I swear oh
I met her at playlist lives why do they
have such bad reputations cuz they do
show like I think Tana has a reputation
because she did some festival thing like
before that from what I was reading is
that people I've always said because she
got popular by doing story time videos
so like she says an experience that she
had and she just really makes it mega
dramatic and people are always saying
like yeah right this didn't happen to
you you're so exaggerating and whatever
so she got to like it for that but then
now like what more of this kind of stuff
so she was bella thorns girlfriend I
think if I was Christian I would hit
them getting married cuz like Oh gay
people they actually love each other oh
my [ __ ] if you guys would love each
other even though it's your marriage is
different than my definition of marriage
you guys actually love Travon oh if they
really love each other yeah so they've
been reporting that babe only you can't
wear a matching red denim jacket with
your jeans and say you love someone what
I do love about this type of
relationship though is like it's like
it's like hey it's like he asked me to
marry him and then he texts her and he's
like hey didn't tag me can you take this
down like that kind of [ __ ] happens
God's life you know that [ __ ] actually
happens I love that she didn't or if
this became a betting event
Vegas but you have the horse races the
basketball whatever and then how long
then in the last actually take bets on
how we dope they'll be tight youtuber
couples and celebrity couples how long
is it gonna be a good bad what are the
Vegas odds on that you gotta wait years
though I know this made me feel like if
this all if this is all fake because
jake has come out and said that one of
his previous relationships would just it
was fake it was just for the fun of you
see fast Christian I'd be mad that's why
people now are saying like what the [ __ ]
like if this is real I'm pissed
if this is fake I'm pissed oh it doesn't
even matter because they've only been
dating for a couple months and they've
just I don't know for some reason it
upsets people I can't relate to that but
a lot of you so the girl was gay no well
she was in a relationship I think she's
buyers buy okay yeah so I wonder if they
have fake threesomes too good no wonder
because if I always thought to myself if
I was gonna be like a fake celeb and
have all these like fake relationships
for like the likes and whatever right
like can we [ __ ] like - like for real
though yeah but then no strings attached
so it's kind of like Oh young - like
she's 21 she just turned 22 so people
are like this ain't gonna last if this
is all just for the fame and so it makes
me think like how far do people really
do I do did a boxing match oh yeah I
watched it oh yeah cuz you're a boxer
right red you watch it yeah watch that
man it was so weak I knew you'd be what
like tired out off - just off the first
round both of them were tired oh yeah
but what about from coming from a boxer
and a boxing fan did you feel like
people that are now just doing these
random celebrity boxing matches do you
feel like they disrespect or sport or
you actually enjoy seeing them fight I
enjoy handling beefs that way that's
that's dope yeah I I think that cuz what
did they have like a beef or something
and think so yeah yeah so that's what I
was it real though we don't know oh yeah
we don't know
yes so I'm cool with there being like
that they handle the beef that way like
I remember even when Chris Brown is
Soulja Boy was gonna do and make every
day I was all for it you know
I look forward to the day of like
somebody be fit with me like yes we
should do a celebrity boxing right I
look forward to that you know you post
your training you can't post your
training you got it look like a boy yeah
I don't want to do it I want to see
someone fight him you guys sound like
you're beefing right now no nobody could
do I want to see someone spy him and get
that ass because you hear what he just
said about you that's what I said he
kicked my ass I don't get my ass kicked
the it okay if I ever do have a beef
which I don't I don't receive it yeah I
mean we do took it out in the ring you
know I'm saying I for sure wanted to get
Jake like oh you know I thought about
Justin Bieber guess you could call that
he called out Tom Tom Cruise
yeah and he's and then he also like he's
been working with Mayweather's camp sew
it down like bro I pretty sure I
understand weight class I will for sure
like getting the ring with you he's
working with the money you out babe yeah
yeah I'm Justin out [ __ ] with you bro
like I'll get in the ring with you man
you dare fight anybody for the fame no
Anthony fighters don't know no
professional like would you be down to
get your ass beat for the fame if we're
money who said I was gonna get my ass
beat it's all for Honor girl I'm a
samurai no I just wanna like by a
youtuber that I could beat up for sure
you could find a kid youtuber yeah but
those candles there you go why you gotta
calm out you're [ __ ] opening up toys
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] your hands up if your
mom says okay we would love to fight you
you want to make slime I'll [ __ ] your
slime up to will turn you into slime we
make slime he just became his manager
what I call anyone out I feel like I
kind of I'm kind of over all that I
don't know that don't like a [ __ ] I'm
too tired for that [ __ ] I mean the idea
of like and I'm gonna wake up tomorrow
and I gotta figure out like okay we're
gonna set up some fight somewhere am I
want to do it you love you've been on
YouTube for a long time have you beef
with anybody ever
yeah I used to beef with all the fake
prankers I used to tweet tweet at them
and all that stuff sure I would just
tweet like you know hey nice fake video
I'll reelect your fake video no not
really I think a couple times uh one
time some girl called me up she was a
fellow tuber I can't remember her name
because she's irrelevant and she tried
to call I was kid but she tried to call
me out for like I was talking to people
during Harry Potter they were all
playing Quidditch they're all walking
around on brooms and [ __ ] throwing balls
and I went there and I interviewed them
and I was making fun women chat and so I
got called out for like asking girls
sexual questions it was like this is
sexual harassment and I was like oh cool
so just talking about sex with people is
sexual harassment and she was like oh no
I don't she backed off yeah I'm sorry
that you were raised to think that sex
is bad like I was just asking them
questions and they were answering and
they were in my video like it wasn't
like she got too horny Steve she was
warning you better bothered bothered I
don't like those those fake prank videos
because the people some people don't
know that they're fake and they get
influenced to do prank videos and they
actually do that the real [ __ ] and it's
like they actually like get in fights
and say like you know me aren't they say
they're [ __ ] with real people is
random whatever but like the prank like
the real like the fake pranks you could
tell like yes they're hell of fate it's
so easy to tell people don't know people
don't realize so if they are blurring
them that means like blurring out other
people they're adding to like so how how
real it could be or the does that make
it more of a dead giveaway is when they
walk up to a stranger that stranger has
already locked up but here this hole has
already been briefed by a director and
he's already been locked up it's like
you wanted the sound quality is perfect
[Music]